cool so i just want to give everybody
sort of um
is the mic
can you hear me not great
can i okay
our mic was not working earlier so maybe
we're not working good okay great
so um yeah so first i just want to give
everybody sort of an idea about um about
how i kind of want the discussion to go
so we're going to start out where what
i'm going to do is just um in case you
didn't have a chance to read the paper
or you're confused about things i'm
going to sort of give a summary of the
things i think that are the most
interesting parts of the paper um just
so that everybody can kind of be on the
same page
and then we'll have a little bit of time
to talk about things that you want but
then we're going to try something new
where i've pre-appointed some people to
be discussion leaders and if you feel
like you want to be a discussion later
too then you can just raise your hand at
that point in time and we'll break up
with the smaller groups to try to try
maybe
you know in groups of like five to ten
people just um talking about it so that
you can have you know a chance to to ask
questions but you know maybe if you're
nervous about talking in front of the
whole group you don't have to be nervous
it's only ten people um you know
whatever so so we'll give that a shot
so um
so with that in mind um this paper
is about sparrow
um
so sparrow is a
um the thing i think that really
captures sparrow best is
um or least the thing that they wrote
the capture sparrow best is that it's a
decentralized randomized sampling
approach um for scheduling that provides
near optimal performance and
scalability
now um something that i kind of want to
plant the seed of in your mind is that
although this paper talks about sparrow
in reference to things like you know
compared to hadoop or compared to spark
um i also think that sparrow is really
something that if you we've all probably
dealt with load balancers at some point
and the sparrow really kind of looks
like a load balancer if you sort of till
your head a little bit um and so i kind
of want to just plant that seed while we
start talking about some of the
techniques that they use
um because i think that's that's
actually really interesting really
interesting thing in this paper
so um
so so what is sparrow well the idea is
that
is that what we had was
we have these frameworks like hadoop and
what hindu does is it improves this
thing that we used to do before
and there's a microphone
so
what we used to do was
we had
some computers
and what we would do is we have some
problem so like here's a problem
and we make our problem into some data
and then we would send that over to the
computer and that's what we did like i
don't know 15 years ago 10 years ago
then hadoop came out and we changed this
around
do you have an enough marker for an
eraser oh you can use the about yeah
so what we did then was we
changed this so that instead of sending
our
compute to the data
we sent or sorry
the data to the compute we would send
our programs to the data
so now but what does it mean to send a
program
in this case our program is some kind of
binary
application
and what was the win here
well our program our problem data it
kept getting bigger and bigger maybe you
know over here we got like 10 gigabytes
of data
and our applications
even when our applications are really
big they're not that big maybe i don't
know say 100 megabytes for a really big
application
so it was more efficient to send our
program over to the data
but sparrow changes that again
and what we do in sparrow
is
we send our
data to the compute to the data
um
and so what i mean by that is so we have
our our problem okay it's like you know
10 gigs or whatever and the sparrow
paper they mentioned things like yarn
and slurm and mesos if you know what i'm
talking about and you read the paper and
you're like cool this will make some
it'll make sense you didn't read it it
doesn't really matter if there's these
things they don't matter
what we so what we do is we take these
programs and we send them over to the
data but the problem still is this
program is 100 megabytes now uploading
100 megabyte file takes like a second or
two but one of the motivations of spark
is what they want to do is they want to
make it so that you can just log on to a
website and get real-time interactive
queries where you can you know maybe
like you jump to your email and you
don't just see your email but it
searches every email that everybody in
your company has ever sent
but not just your company everything in
some multinational conglomerate and it
doesn't just filter all those emails but
it also applies like privacy rules to
them so you can't see secret stuff
so we want to do lots of computation
and the problem is that all those rules
they start to get pretty big to encode
if we want to send over the application
itself
so with sparrow what we're trying to do
is we're saying well
really
the data is just like the string email
and then
what we're going to do is we're sending
this string over to the program you know
which is bigger and the program is
hopefully we already sent it over to the
data and so what we end up doing is we
end up sort of
being able to send in even smaller
amounts of data
in transit which helps us it's one of
the ways that we can improve performance
so
that is
sort of the design goal
so then
okay this chair i don't know if you have
another chair oh yeah
cool
so um
so basically
this is the idea
now i want to draw another parallel here
so
does everybody knows how http works or
like making a web request even if you
didn't know those http that's that's
over http
so really in that case we're doing just
that
you and your http request send your
little request that's data
it goes over to a web server that's some
compute and that web server lives in the
data center near some databases that's
your your big problem data
so really in some sense what we're doing
is sparrow is taking inspiration from
this this web application architecture
where our clients are sending requests
to our servers and our servers make up
responses and send them back
now
there's a few things though that sparrow
does differently
differently than it is than a regular
load balancer within a regular sort of
web app and there's really there's three
things i think that are that are most
interesting
so those three things are
one second
all right so those three things are
power of two scheduling
batch sampling and empirical
measurements
so let's go over each of these things in
turn
so one thing i think that um the sparrow
paper it really it just doesn't go it
doesn't explain at all is this power of
two sampling there's a little bit about
it but it's a really interesting idea
and um i think that it's also something
that even without understanding much
about statistics it's something that we
can all get so
this is the one thing that if you get
nothing else out of the paper and if you
get nothing else to explain to you
this thing i want to make sure that
everybody has some idea how it works
can you guys not hear me in the back
nope
okay
can you just hear me if i talk like this
okay great i'll just talk like this wow
so um
right so so what's the idea here so
normally let's look at like um
we have this thing called um request
latencies right what that means is
sometimes when i make a request to some
system it takes 10 milliseconds
sometimes takes 100 milliseconds and
what we can do is we can actually
visualize that
so what we can do is we can make an axis
where this axis is the latency
and generally if we look at it it looks
something like this
so over here these are low latencies
over here these are high latencies
does this chart make sense to people
okay
so now
the goal is
we want to do two things one thing is
instead of it looking like this red
chart
say red is bad
we want it to look more like this green
chart
which is good
and what this means is we're not seeing
you know some really fast some really
slow we're trying to sort of make them
all be about the same speed
the other thing that we want to happen
is we just want to shift this as far to
the left as possible
so those are the two goals and so power
of two scheduling is how we're going to
do that
so the idea here is
well what if we could guess and what if
we knew in advance and we said well some
machines we know they're over here on
the right side in some machines we know
they're over here on the left side
all right and so what we're going to do
is we're going to say well if we always
pick machines on the left side
then we're always going to be doing
better than the middle
now that doesn't exactly make sense
because if you're always doing better
than the middle well that is where you
know the middle moves as you continue to
beat it so at some point you can't do
better and you just get to as best as it
can be
and so that's this power of two
scheduling idea
so
let's see what that looks like
so the idea is what happens if we pick
random servers
well random servers you know we could be
anywhere here and that's that's what
this chart represents
but if we do power of two
what we're going to get is this
a little chart little um square
so
this side is one request
and this side is the other request
because remember we're checking two
servers to see which one is going to
actually serve up our request
now each of these servers there's two
types here
there could be there's gonna be two fast
servers
and there's gonna be two
slow servers
so
each of these squares happens with 25 of
the time you know 25 of the time this
request is going to get a server that is
faster than half of the others 25 or
sorry 50 of the time this request is
faster than half 25 percent of the time
this one is fast it's slower than half
so what does this mean when we look at
this chart
well
it means that
in
three out of the four cases
we actually end up with a faster request
than the median
in only one of the four cases we end up
with a slower request
so
this is some this um i think this is a
nicer sort of intuitive model for why
the power of two scheduler does so much
better
now
we can actually see how much better it
does
by a chart that they have
let me find that chart
so if you have the paper it's on page
four
if you don't have the paper i'm just
gonna sketch it really quick
so i've tried to color match the chart
in the paper so what we have here is we
have four little things where this axis
is the response time in milliseconds
and this other axis is
um the load
the load that sort of represents the
difficulty factor so um
you know generally obviously if you only
if you only ever get one request at a
time to your system it's always gonna do
great you know things get harder when
there's more things going on so
um basically but i would consider this
sort of the the difficulty of the
problem we're trying to solve
so we see is that in the red case that's
where we just pick a random server and
we can see that you know as requests
increase the latency increases
now with the blue one though that's
where we start adding that red this
power of two sampling and you can see
that actually for a while it does pretty
well and it only starts to to perform
poorly the further we go on
now the green one
what the green one does is something
called batch sampling which is the
second point in this paper but i think
it's pretty interesting
so um before i go into batch template
though i want to find i want to ask does
anybody have any questions about the
power of two stuff or sort of the
motivating factors of this paper
it's not clear why they call it power
too
ah they call it power of two because
i think it's originally the power of two
choices power two choices okay power
really you gain power by having natural
choices uh uh
popularized by michael visnocker
uh in some of his early
in some of his work after grad school
where basically it's
for
a generalized problem of load balancing
you actually have a much tighter bound
on the expected
uh
max load of any bin in a you're randomly
allocating balls to bins if you pick the
men of two random choices
um this past few choices
you should read the papers by michael
mitsumoto they're very good
right so that's that's
another way to think about it or the way
that i like to think about it um and
this is something that as we sort of go
through batch sampling dlc is that in
this case essentially what we're doing
is um we're picking when we say we pick
two servers you see 75 percent of the
time we do better but what if we instead
for each one of these we chose four
servers well then we'd have this like 16
element matrix and if you go through the
16 element matrix and see how often
say instead you look at the fastest
quarter server now and then you look at
the 16 element matrix and you'll see
that actually you know
more a bigger chunk of the 16 element
matrix will be in this we're doing
better than the median cam
so you know it's also there and that
it's um you know you can the power is a
knob that you can turn
um and that's we'll see how you can turn
that with batch sampling better
yeah this assumes all the servers are
equal in their ability to serve
it does um now the last thing that we
look at the empirical measurement that
is going to
compensate for the fact that our
idealized model of all servers are equal
isn't true and instead we're going to
say how are servers doing right at this
moment and we're going to schedule based
on that information so
cool
so
batch sampling batch sampling is another
thing that i think is um
it's really cool
trying to figure out how to get the ink
off the board
so for batch sampling um
the paper i think has a really great
example so i'm just going to
reiterate the papers example for why
batch assembling works
so let's look at two example probes now
there's two types of servers we're gonna
call them fast servers and slow servers
okay
so we have request one
and request one
it's going to get
two slow servers
then we also have request two
and request two is going to get two fast
servers
so what this means now is the request
one its response time is going to be
slower than median but request two its
response time is going to be faster than
median
what batch sampling says is it says hey
why don't we just
do this all as a batch
so we'll probe four servers for both
requests simultaneously and then we'll
take the best servers out of all of
those probes and we'll use those
together
and when we do this
then we see that actually both requests
will get a fast server where had we
probed them separately they would not
have both got fast servers
and this just generalizes so the higher
the throughput that you get the more
probes you can do simultaneously and
then the
the more the more there exists different
sort of shuffling where oh you know this
one this one had a really good luck
probe and this isn't a really bad luck
probe so we'll just kind of share that
information among them so we get a
better result overall
so that's this batch sampling idea
and this is something also that you know
i mean i think
i i really want to i think that i like
about this paper so much is that they're
taking these ideas that are really
popular in like um in web architectures
and in improving performance of
databases and improving performance
really of everything and they're just
applying it to this different domain
so you know we saw this power of two
scheduling which came from load
balancing now we're seeing this batch
sampling which is really we're just
saying let's just batch all the requests
and try to you know get some better work
done here um this is something where if
you ever use mongodb even you know by
i don't know if they still did this by
default but for a while there was a lot
of people did not like mongodb because
it would try to bash up the rights as it
made them what that meant was that if
you killed mongodb at the wrong time
you'd lose all the rights in the batch
that hadn't been written yet
but you know this is this is a trick
that um
it's pretty popular to use and it's
something that you can take away and
sort of see that you know works in
really small things that don't work well
works really big systems that are fast
um
so that's batch sampling
does anybody have any questions about
batch sampling
yeah when the requests are hitting the
server how are they deciding like which
one is best do they have to go back and
tell
where they were sent from or how does
that
decision made
so so what happens is so let me draw
another chart to explain this
so what we do is we have these um i'll
move out of the way in a second
we have these things these sparrows okay
and then we have some workers
and each of the workers
has a queue
so what happens is a user connects to
one of the sparrow schedulers
and then the sparrow scheduler
randomly picks some workers in this case
we're doing the power of two picking
right and so what it does is going to
connect to pick those workers that i
picked and say hey workers how many
elements are in your queue
and we're going to say the number of
elements in a worker's queue represents
how fast that worker is because sort of
intuitively you know the more work it
has the longer the queue the longer it's
going to take for it to answer and you
know conversely you know the shorter the
queue the faster it's going to answer
so does that answer your question i
think so yeah cool
did you have a question um so i just
want to make sure
that requests one request two are two
different requests that the same person
is making
and instead of sending off each request
independently
you're sending them together
and you're sending it to all four
servers instead of each request
individually sending two servers right
so so the idea is that these these
requests these requests are coming into
the sparrow schedulers okay now the
sparrow schedulers though they need to
make these probes which are represented
by these arrows
um and so these are the probe results so
what we're saying is well if one sparrow
scheduler
has if for each request it probes them
independently and does not share
information between
those probes
then it's not going to do as well as if
instead every 50 milliseconds it batches
up all of the probes all of the requests
that it's gotten does all of those
approach simultaneously and then looks
at the best results of those okay
um double checking yeah
right it's basically the idea is that by
when you treat them all independently
you're going you're you get this you
know you get the one result which is
sort of the power of two improvement but
when you do the batch result you have
these other cases like where you know
one of them is especially bad or one of
them is especially good and then that
additional shared information results in
it gives you a better result okay
uh or in the back
uh is there an optimal size of the batch
size like you mean it would make sense
for you to like
wait until the batch is the size of like
all your workers right right so so the
idea with the batching is really it ends
up being um being um sort of a
a latency performance trade-off where
the longer you wait the bigger your
batch the bigger the batch the better
the results but the whole point of
bashing is to reduce latency so you
don't want to wait too long because then
you're defeating the purpose of the
operation
so um so generally i mean when it comes
to batching the paper actually explains
two different batching techniques one of
them is that well so first of all
remember sparrow is really targeted at
these mapreduce computations so
when you're doing a mapreduce job
the
the thing that comes in the sparrow
results in sparrow knowing it needs to
execute a thousand tasks say which means
they can just immediately make two
thousand probes with zero that doesn't
weight at all it just knows and
instantly that's what it needs to do
there is um
it goes into more detail about um about
placement constraints and there's some
problems with this this type of batching
with placement constraints and for that
from for that based on my reading of the
paper it seems like it waits like every
10 milliseconds it takes everything
that's happened over that 10 millisecond
period and batches that together
is there a question over here yeah so
each of those sparrow nodes is making a
couple of requests but they're separate
uh you know there's they're separate
machines so there's added overhead then
and for them to coordinate their results
to find the best results free you know
across the batch as opposed to each
individual spiral nodes answer
so that's actually it's a great question
so the idea with sparrow is that um an
individual sphero node coordinates an
individual user intention so if the user
intends for something that results in a
thousand tasks getting executed then
that one sphero node's going to manage
all of those tasks
um
if the now the one of the powerful
features of sparrow is that it's um it's
a share nothing architecture you know
this is something that most web
applications try to do this they try to
move all their state into the database
and in this case
our database
is the cues on the workers
so
instead of these um sparrow nodes
needing to communicate between each
other to coordinate something or to load
balance you know and to somehow you know
meet their goals by communicating
instead they communicate when they talk
to a worker and discover how long the
queue is on that worker that the queue
length is sort of that is the data
storage for the information of interest
to sparrow
the batching so the bashing is done
inside of the sparrow node
um the q the workers are really dumb the
only thing a worker can do is say
um it can execute a task or it can
accept a task to be enqueued and give
you a response later and it can also
tell you how much is in the queue that's
all that's all that workers need to do
for now there's they'll do something new
in a few minutes
any more matching
cool
so
now the next thing um
the kind of the last thing that i think
is really important to the sparrow paper
is this idea of empirical measurement
and i believe they call this
late finding
so
and it is they call not only do they
call light binding but it really is
light binding it's late binding in the
sense of
um
you know closure has some late binding
features some other i think erlang has
some late binding features in it um
there's a lot of languages that have a
lot of things and they all call them
late binding and they are all late
binding
sparrow is another instance of this sort
of pattern
so um
so there's a problem with everything
that i said here
um it's a really big problem and it
turns out in practice um that when you
look at it these ideas are good but
they're not great they don't really they
don't really make sparrow into an
awesome schedule they make it into a
more into a substantial improvement over
the state of the art but not like not
like killer
and so this late binding thing that's
what makes sparrow killer
so what's the idea here
well
these sparrow nodes and the way that it
decides fast or slow that's all based on
cue length right we look at some things
and we say oh this q is you know 10
elements long this one three elements
long the three element long one must be
faster than the 10 element long one
um but then that might not be true what
if the 10 element cues jobs i'll take 10
milliseconds and the three element cues
jobs each take a thousand milliseconds
then the 10 element queue is
um
six times faster
so
it would be a really bad idea if um
if we went on qdep alone so instead what
we're going to do is we're going to
measure and we're going to see which
queue is actually faster
um now at this point you might be saying
okay but that's pretty weird because
what you're saying you're saying you ask
a question now about a thing that's
going to happen in the future because
right now i want to find out whenever
they're done who is finished first or
who will be finished first but we're
asking that without having any
information about what was happening so
how do we do that
um the way we do it
is that we're going to take this
communication model and make it a little
bit more complicated so i'm going to
make another diagram for that
so
we have our sparrow node here
and we have our worker
over here
going to be a four a four-way handshake
that these two are going to do
the first thing sparrow is going to do
is it's going to say
reservation
uh it means make me a reservation on
this worker and so at this point what
the worker does is it puts a little
thing into a queue
saying all right
i got you you're right here you're
like fifth in line now
and
so when sparrow is a probe the probes
they don't they don't actually measure
the queue depth anymore now our probe is
like it's like making a little ticket
like when you go to the deli counter or
the bakery counter and you take one of
those tickets that's what we're gonna do
now
and so what happens at some point the
worker's gonna say um you know great
uh it's your turn
are you still interested in this because
i mean i'm sure we've all went to the
deli or you know any of those things
with the ticket things and um got really
pissed off that it took so long and just
stormed out kept our ticket it's like
nobody else can have this ticket i
waited all that time to get anything
so they can't either
um
and that's okay you know that happens in
sparrow too
so so you know so the deli worker um is
going to say to the sparrow say hey like
do you want to run your job now because
it's your turn if you're interested
um at that point the worker can say yeah
sure
um here's my job
and we're gonna pass that job on over
and at this point now
the the worker actually is going to run
the job for real
and then finally in the final stage
we're going to send the results back
now what this does compared to the um
the the q depth probe is that
what we're doing is by putting in the
reservation
the the time that we get the first okay
that
is the fastest one of whichever ones we
probed you know we don't care which ones
we probed but when we get that okay back
we know that one is ready because
actually the node is idle it's not
actually computing anything when it says
okay
and then when we run the job it gets
immediately run with zero latency
now
you might say well this is great you
know we've just we've eliminated all the
uncertainties due to q depths being a
poor approximation of the actual
q
amount of work that's pending on that
node
uh what's the penalty
well the penalty here
is um
is in this little region and i'm
scribbling in red
see between the time that the worker
says okay
and the job
gets back to the worker the worker can't
do anything because it's waiting for
somebody to tell it what to do next
so
what ends up happening here is that
this late binding thing
it's more effective
as the network latencies become short or
the job lanes become long so longer jobs
and faster networks this is a good idea
if your jobs your networks are equal
length then this reservation idea
doesn't work because you end up sitting
idle for an entire job's worth of work
and your throughput just goes through
the floor or hits the floor and then
sort of stays there
now there is another um
there's another really interesting thing
in this paper or actually so
all right
so this is this empirical measurement
thing um does anybody have any questions
about this empirical measurement yeah
doesn't this then also
uh need basically a cue on the sparrow
worker too of like the jobs that are
waiting to be done as opposed to waiting
on the workers like you've moved the
queue basically at this point
so
there was there's always um sort of the
set of pending tasks on the sparrow
worker because it needs to know what's
still outstanding yeah right um
i i would call it less of a cue
okay yeah there is a queue also on the
sparrow warner so the sparrow worker
knows what needs to be done
it makes all the reservations in a big
bash and then as it gets okay it starts
tren shifting its cue from here to here
so yeah we did we shuffled the queues
around a little bit i'm just thinking of
reliability like
like if you lose a worker you lose four
jobs into the batch sampling but if you
lose you use a sparrow node then you've
lost a lot more jobs in this in this
setup so actually um am i wrong so
you are but not for the reason you think
so
in both cases you lose all the jobs the
um the idea with sparrow is that the
scheduler is stateless the idea is that
there's some client saying i want you to
run this job and if the sparrow node
dies before the client gets its result
it just submits it to a different
sparrow
so that that's that's sort of the
underlying assumption throughout the
paper so yeah so you don't you don't
lose anything more if you try to shift
the persistence over here um then
actually you're starting to move away
from the shared nothing architecture and
there's all kinds of new distributed
problems you get to deal with right yeah
the client the final source of truth
with like what needs to be done exactly
right so
so yeah
does this barrel only uh reserve the
task on one worker or multiple workers
so these reservations these are
replacing those those probes either
those power of two probes or the batch
probes so what happens is sparrow gets
you know gets some job that job is a
thousand tasks then this barrow node now
that it has those thousand tests it's
gonna make two thousand reservations the
first thousand reservations that it gets
an okay for those are going to run the
jobs the second thousand
um they're we're just gonna ignore them
because we're not interested anymore
yeah
i think they actually oh
yes was there some consideration
in the paper i don't know i'm sorry i
didn't read it to uh
you know say well why do a reservation
why don't you send the job but then when
the worker's ready it says hey i'm
actually running it
and that could be sort of the protocol
was that
so i don't think that they talked about
that yeah um i mean one of the reasons i
mean yeah i think that that would
definitely um improve um for certain
types of workloads um you know if we go
back to that idea about like how much
data are we transmitting you know it may
be that a job is a little bit bigger um
i think generally the idea is that a
probe is like we're on the order of
bytes you know a job is kilobytes um so
you know it's a thousand that's more
communication
throughput is required to send the job
as part of the reservation but for
certain workloads you could definitely
do that
um i think it was
so
if the worker's just coming back to the
scheduler every time that needs a new
job and you're sending the job at the
time that it requests it how is this
particularly different than just a fifo
q on the sparrow side and a producer
consumer problem like a classic producer
consumer scheduler doesn't it just kind
of eliminate the entire batch sample
empirical measurement model like
so so you mean with the idea about why
does the worker call back so like the
sparrow makes a call out to multiple
workers and it's effectively saying i
can cue all of you for the next thing
that i have to run
and then the workers all come back and
say like i have a thing like i have a
slot to run on and the sparrow scheduler
just hands back to him how is this
different than just just that step like
how does power 2 batch sample and even
the statement of like this is late
binding but how does everything else
factor in that makes it fundamentally
different from just the workers
requesting work uh yes so i think that
so so basically um i'm gonna try to
summarize it into like a one phrase and
see if you agree um so what you're
saying is like um
if we just had one big shared queue that
all the workers are reading from how is
this different than that
two well i mean you're shorting across
sparrows right but even
like why is each sparrow not just one
big sure queue yeah right so um so the
thing is so if each sparrow was one big
shared queue then that means that each
worker needs to know about every sparrow
i mean does it because effectively uh it
has been like
you're setting up a queue of
reservations across sparrows you're
saying like right i go back to this
sparrow this time in this row this time
you could easily flip it around and say
this worker approaches random sparrows
whenever it has work ready um like
so that's a great point um and so
you may have heard something called work
stealing um and yeah there's there is
really there's a really interesting um
um going back to the first papers below
i missed the second one i don't know if
duality came out there too but there
yeah there is a sort of a duality
between this sparrow model and work
stealing where in work stealing
our workers are pulling data and here we
are pushing workers to pull data um so
maybe maybe as a duality maybe it's
really just on sort of a subset relation
but yeah there is those are very similar
ideas um yeah
my question was just um
if the worker says okay i'm ready and
the sparrow is no longer interested does
it actively have to send a message to
say i'm not interested or does the
worker just time out ah
i'll get back to that
yeah how about prioritying the jobs
prioritizing the jobs i'll also get back
to that
all right
yes
so you have uh two star notes and
they all probe a
random sample of the workers but
if you if you're a client and you want
to run something on some workers just
because you ask that one spiral node
to run your job it doesn't mean that his
workers the workers that he are going to
have
three slots like you might if you had
pinged a different sparrow then you
might have had a free slot faster and
if you waited for it for that one one
node and
so i'm not really sure how they deal
with that in it also how they deal with
like over capacity so
one worker goes back to you and says i
have one slot but you need 10 to run
right how do i deal with that so um all
right so me
answer
the second one first so um
each job
the idea with sparrow is um answered
both both of those at the same time
the idea with sparrow is that we're
using um we're using randomized
algorithms
instead of trying to get
instead of trying to come up with a
solution that solves the actual optimal
problem we're going to use a randomized
algorithm that approaches the optimal
solution and the reason that we use the
randomized algorithm that approaches the
optimal solution
rather than doing everything is that you
can get much higher scheduling
throughput
some of the examples they gave was so
they talk about a system called spark
spark is the sort of in-memory mapreduce
that's become very popular for like
analytics stuff because you can get an
answer to your you know a hadoop job
that took 10 minutes on spark it takes
maybe one or two seconds um and so
sparrow it was designed by the same left
and spark came out of and they're like
okay what do we do for the next step
what if spark wasn't just for research
or for like analytics people but it was
actually for every single request was a
spark job
and so the idea there is well
if you just look at the
number of scheduling decisions you need
to make per second each note you would
need to make
millions to hundreds of millions of
scheduling decisions per second now if
you consider like you know a really
beefy server like you know how big of a
server do you for like 10 grand
maybe like 40 or 50 cpus couple hundred
gigs of ram like you think this is
really fast but that machine is going to
get to make you know ten thousand uh
decisions per second maybe a hundred
thousand scheduling decisions per second
um and so in order to achieve that level
of scalability where you can actually
solve you know infinite number of these
per second i mean by continuing to throw
more machines and also with the caveat
that at some point nothing works um but
you know to do a lot better
you need to
start splitting the stuff between the
multiple sparrows you need to trust the
randomized algorithm
in expectation works well and generally
and with and basically the idea is
randomized stuff it works pretty well
the power of two thing really helps
control the tail latencies the late
binding helps deal with the fact that we
can't estimate um q-depths accurately
and so you know when you look at it in
practice it actually works really well
now coming back to the capacity problem
um
so that is that's actually really
interesting question um so you know what
happens if you have if your cluster can
serve you know a billion requests and
you get a billion and a half requests
like what do you do um well you fall
over
that's the only answer to that question
um and that's and that's something you
know you see this in um
most companies that start getting really
big data centers with like hundreds to
you know thousands to tens of thousands
of machines
what they do is
they do capacity planning and they
ensure that they have
more capacity available for serving than
they do for the requests
and um and when they do start hitting
that capacity limit they start rejecting
requests and you can see even in the
server in the um sparrow paper that when
they hit around 80 to 90 load um the
algorithm starts doing very poorly i
mean it still doesn't solve the problem
when you can actually serve the load so
let's say that this power node
like it needs to serve
and test by 10 slots uh but it only asks
for servers
so and and the total like cluster
capacity is 100. so you could serve
the
the request you just couldn't serve it
because you get a very specific spiral
randomization and
so like and then you can't eat over 50
because then your your latency of your
scheduler essentially goes up right like
so in randomized algorithms bad luck
doesn't really happen yeah that's just
you just have to accept that bad luck
isn't the problem um and like um
what it really comes down to is the idea
is that what is bad luck it's like it's
you're flipping a coin and every time
you flip you get tails and so you know
to do what you're saying you'd have to
flip you know thousands of coins and get
a streak of thousands of tails in a row
and um and what you can do and i'm not
gonna i'm just gonna hand way through
this so
what you can do is actually um you can
calculate like based on the rate of
requests and the um
the odds of
getting it wrong is that actually the
universe or the earth is going to get
swallowed by the sun before it doesn't
um probably before you like get bad luck
um
that works
i i yeah if you want to um like
you know what we're like in small groups
i can like actually
prove that but um
but i have to yeah it's not super the
proof is not interesting
well
that's super interesting
yes this battle machine
oh man that's a great question actually
i don't know if they're cpu or i o bound
um
yeah
it's i mean both the cpu and the i o
problems they have are pretty small i
would guess io mount because the cpu
problem they have is like
so freaking trivial that i would be
like shocked if this saturated accord to
like you know i mean because you're just
saying choose like 10 000 out of you
know 100 000 like that i would guess
that it's the network um card is what
saturates first
so it cannot be too much writing into
hard disk or it will be deleted uh
there's no no disk activity and i'm not
even exp there is no hard disk in any of
these things yeah
so yeah
cool so i'm gonna get back now to your
question about what happens if you don't
want it
okay so there's two possible things you
can do one of them is you get this okay
and you send them a job but it's a
special job that says i don't care and
then
to get your special result back saying
like yeah me neither
so
you know what if we do that
well if you send this i don't care and
then you get this result back me neither
then you're actually going to pay a big
you're paying like a pretty big latency
cost because now you're not just paying
this little thing between the okay and
the job getting back you're paying
another um you know idle time which is
the time that it takes to actually
receive this you know and decide you
don't care and then send back the i
don't care
so the other thing that you can do is is
something called proactive cancellation
and what this means is that instead of
saying um
is that what you say is you say you know
actually hey like i'm not going to be
here anymore so when you're done you
have sort of you know some other i don't
know out-of-band communication mechanism
saying like never mind this is awful you
can't read this
um
yeah
so you have this nevermind rpc that um
lets you just say like yeah whatever
there's an interesting thing about like
what is the right which is which is
better is this better or is this better
and they have a they have an interesting
discussion of this so turn so remember i
just want to kind of remind everyone um
the reason we're doing this is because
the network links the network's latency
is much faster than the time it takes to
solve a problem
so
because that's true
this little exchange about the the i
don't the the like you know i don't care
messages that should be really cheap
proactive cancellation helps
as the network becomes slower or the
jobs become faster so you know we're
going
in the direction that makes this less
useful proactive cancellation helps to
mitigate the penalty of those i don't
care um there's no op jobs
so it really depends on the exact
workload you're running which is the one
you want
yeah so what's the additional cost of
that it doesn't seem like much because
you still have to send the i don't care
back for the pro for the proactive
cancellation so the idea is that um you
might still be in the middle of the
queue
right
so now this machine still has a set idle
for this period but you get to skip this
idle period
right yeah so that's all you're doing
but like so if your if your network
takes 10 milliseconds to make a network
call and your jobs take 50 milliseconds
you just save like 20 percent
right well so it basically sounds like
you're moving the item care message
earlier in time exactly so what is there
an additional cost to that
um because it seems like you just may as
well just do it yeah um
let's see i think that they actually
have a reason maybe that doesn't work
um
yeah no i don't think it really yeah i
think it's probably just probably better
just to always productively cancel um
there is code complexity there though
that for some problems just doesn't
matter
yeah
is there an assumption that forwarding
this to a friend would be negligibly
faster than just flipping to the next
reservation in the work queue
um so like uh the sparrow node has just
gotten a
handle for a worker that can do
something why if it doesn't care why
doesn't it just hand it over to one of
its neighbors and that neighbor process
it as opposed to
saying i don't care and then
that time existing and then the worker
having to contact someone else you
eliminate one of those calls by just
contacting it so here there's a damning
sentence in this paper that talks about
that where they say we don't need to
implement complex bug-ridden gossip
protocols uh the bug written part i just
added but com they call it complex um
you know i think that and this also
really goes back to the cancellation
thing is that um you know when you're
designing um uh these high scale
distributed systems um performance is
really is in many cases not it's it
might be the first goal but it's it's
very close second or maybe even tied
with um ease of implementation like you
know when you're building these like
crazy complex things the last thing you
want to do is make it so that you're the
only person on the planet who
understands it you want to make it so
that you know anybody can pick up a
paper and be like okay yeah i sort of
see where you're going there like you
know yeah there's no gossip handshaking
you know you know like crazy time-out
systems
um so i mean i think that it's really a
lot of it a lot of what sparrow's design
comes down to is like how do we strip
away everything you know to result in
this like really simple to implement
thing
um
so yeah
so um
any other questions about these things
so will the people that i elected to be
group leaders or people who want to be
group leaders now raise their hands
all right
we have six group leaders okay
so um so if you just if you had if each
group leader can walk away from each
other and then people can walk towards
group leaders um then you know i want to
try to make it for like 10 minutes we'll
just sort of talk in a smaller thing
about it
cool so um
all right so hopefully everyone had a
chance to discuss some stuff um you know
i definitely heard some interesting
things so like you know if you guys have
things came up in your group and you
want to share them um i'll go first um
so one thing i learned was that actually
um
that is an example of other places where
this kind of randomized sampling is used
to improve scheduling actually like on
oracle and sql server use them as part
of their query planners so they use that
sort of they sample the tables and they
see are they sparse or dense they decide
what types of joins to use in real time
so that's just an example of the
randomized um randomized sampling being
applied and some other you know
scheduling problems
i don't know do other people have things
they wanted to uh that were interesting
that came up or
yeah i have a question that we didn't
totally answered my group and that was i
was just kind of wondering like what on
what scale is this useful how many
worker servers do you need to have
before it pays off to do this sure
so um so in the paper what they talk
about is they talk about that they made
sparrow because they couldn't
they wanted to answer so many requests
that that a single server couldn't
schedule them and so they had something
where it's like thousands of workers and
you know hundreds or thousands of
requests per second
um
so
at two sigma we're hiring on my team um
we do a lot of cool stuff with
distributed systems um one of the things
is we have uh we have a scheduling
problem we're using we actually have two
scheduling problems where we're using
sparrow i'll briefly remark on one of
them without divulging too many secrets
um
so the the problem that we have
is similar in that we have workers we
have problems that are small code which
is big do we want to pre-distribute
we don't know how long it's going to
take um in our case where one of the
ways that we input we have you know like
i don't know 100 worker nodes and maybe
um
we should like 100 worker nodes and
maybe 10 000 clients it's a little very
different distribution um and for us the
reason that we're interested in this is
that it allows us to avoid having
central cues so instead instead of
building a central cueing system we are
sort of just smearing the cues across
the rest of the cluster which means that
we don't need to worry about any of the
um operational overheads of doing that
and we still get um sort of
optimal and expectation schedules coming
out of it
so you know i think that depending on
the types of problems you have you can
you can leverage these same techniques
on really small clusters and still see
benefits especially if the problem you
have doesn't fit all like if our problem
we could solve it with hadoop we
probably would not have done sparrow but
given that our problem was really weird
and it needed something custom
sparrow was the easiest custom algorithm
to implement with a lot of nice
properties so you're implementing the
cues on your workers just in memory or
or using some here's a no turning system
is all just in memory with your own code
i'm not going to say
other uh
questions comments interesting things
that came up
do we have prioritization which i was
asking you yes so right um yeah so
they're so speaking of prioritization um
essentially the way the prioritization
works is in these models i sort of said
each worker has one queue
what we can do instead is give each
worker a bunch of cues and then the
worker itself can decide which queue
it's going to be reading off of so maybe
the worker has three queues like low
medium high priority it always deals
with high priority requests before the
medium before the low and then now you
have priority or maybe instead you want
to do fair sharing so then each user
gets their own cue and the worker just
does like round robin off of those cues
or um or there's more sophisticated
weight and fair sharing on multiple cues
problems so yeah you can get both of
those um
and so really
that turns out to be sort of the only
type of of prioritization scheme that
you can do a sparrow is something you
can represent with a set of queues and
some kind of global decision
what it turns out though is that when
you run this in practice this actually
works really well and you can see that
they get a near perfect um weighted fair
sharing as they dynamically adjust the
two
two users on a cluster and you sort of
see that there's some diagrams of the
paper that show that
on the prioritization front though um
it's not quite as bright um it turns out
that because you can't cancel a task
when it starts running at least in the
algorithm presented in the paper
what that means is that if a low
priority task starts running and it
takes hundreds of milliseconds and say
like three milliseconds after it starts
a high priority test comes in it has to
sit in line behind that low priority
task you can't like kill it and cause
you know shuffle the order so i mean
that doesn't seem like a tough thing to
add to sparrow and you know if you did
then you would you would probably be
able to to really um
get better prioritization
and less kind of slop as you increase
load
other questions comments concerns yes
other than yours they're what good
examples of sparrow in the wild do you
know
so spark spark is sparrow was written
for spark okay um so spark is this like
in-memory mapreduce hadoop sort of thing
and they wrote sparrow
for spark that's that's what this paper
is all about the spark sparrow
um
i know
yeah my implementation is the only other
one that i know of
although
you know i would highly recommend it
like if you know go closure erlang
scala
like all these languages basically any
language that has the primitive where
here's a few channels tell me which one
gave me the answer first if your
language has that you can probably
implement this in a day
um you're getting more parts of this in
a day the batch stuff is kind of tricky
the empirical stuff's really easy
the queueing stuff is medium and it's
kind of cool because like based on the
problem you're interested in or like
what part appeals to you you can just
sort of choose like yeah you know i
think i'm gonna do a power of two
sampling with um prioritization but i'm
not i don't really care about batching i
don't care about the empirical stuff
um or maybe like you know i only want to
do empirical stuff with power of two and
i'm not going to worry about cues or you
know so it's kind of flexible in that
sense
yeah so yeah actually this paper is a
number of different techniques that all
together so like minimize response times
my clients live workers
and what i wanted to ask is like so
maybe something in the wild would be
cool but also like some additions like
paper points it sounds that'd be really
cool to
yeah definitely if there are any um so
there was it goes there's some stuff in
here um particularly
yeah there's a specifically there's a
thank you to um
where was it
um
it was samir agarwal actually um helped
to run the simulations so um
i believe he's at mit
um
and you know i mean generally anybody in
academia it's really easy to find their
email address all over their papers
or any of their favorite offers and
like 70 chance they'll give you their
simulation 30 chance they're saving in
for their next publication
but you know
yeah they're they they they have similar
yeah yeah
straight you just quote them all see who
responds first
so um
but they they definitely have a
simulator because they're there they
have synthetic results for like hundred
thousand machine clusters um they only
test it in practice and like thousands
of clusters okay so yeah
yes i would just say anybody who's
interested in real world load balancing
stuff and it hasn't already read it
should google heroku rap genius
and read about that story they're sort
of like
well
documented it's not food
yeah
so the the heroical rap genius thing
once you read about that
what you should think to yourself is
powerful scheduling would have solved
all their problems
yeah i mean or just i don't know there's
i mean there's there's lots of
power i'm gonna go with power scheduling
any other comments
cool well thanks all for coming